hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2017 american thriller movie
starring a beautiful actress named bella
thorne called you get me
the movie starts with tyler a high
school student who is currently in love
with his beautiful girlfriend alison he
lives with his younger sister tiffany
his family is financially well off but
his life has changed to be more colorful
since he met allison at his school
unfortunately all this time he never
invites her to meet his parents because
they are rarely at home and very busy at
work
they have close friends at school named
gil and lydia
tyler also works as a waiter at a cafe
near the beach where he and his friend
often play together at the beach
one night they want to go to their
friend's party
there alison accidentally runs into an
old friend in san francisco named chase
and she intends to introduce him to
tyler at some point tyler and chase are
talking together
chase reveals that in san francisco
alison used to be a bad girl who likes
to party and would often drink and sleep
with other men
tyler immediately gets angry because
allison has never told him about her
past leading the couple to break up
disappointed he decides to leave the
party leaving allison alone he meets a
beautiful and very rich woman named
holly
she invites him to drive around with her
luxury car he accepts the offer and
starts to tell her that he just broke up
with his girlfriend she tries to calm
him down gradually ends up with partying
and sleeping together at her huge and
wonderful house
the next morning tyler wakes up and goes
straight to holly in the living room
with some photos on the floor
she starts telling her family story that
her father had died long ago and left a
great deal of wealth while her
stepmother travels a lot causing her to
often feel lonely during this time
right now she's very happy that they can
spend the rest of the weekend together
at her house they are bonding all day
and tyler is tempted by holly seduction
for sex at night seemingly forgetting
all about allison
after they are satisfied he realizes
that he has to go home because his
little sister is home alone
he says that the weekend is very special
before leaving holly's house when he
gets home he checks his cell phone and
finds that he has received a lot of
messages from his closest people
including allison telling him where to
meet her to solve their problem a few
days earlier the following day he rushes
to allison's house alison apologizes for
her behavior and recounts that while in
san francisco she was affected by her
bad association there that's why her
family chooses to move here hoping to
live a better life they finally admit
and forgive each other's mistakes back
then and they choose to get back
together again in the end they also
promise not to keep secrets from each
other
however tyler seems to remember his
mistake for sleeping with holly last
weekend but he still chooses to keep the
secret from allison in the new semester
at school there is a new student who
enters tyler's class and it turns out to
be holly she reveals that now she and
her stepmother move in the area forever
and wants to surprise him that she goes
to the same class with tyler after class
ends the group gathers in the cafeteria
for lunch and suddenly holly comes and
introduces herself to join them a panic
tyler instantly messages holly to meet
him downstairs near the elevator later
they finally see each other after school
at first she thinks that he wants to
make out with her but apparently he
wants to say that he wants to break up
with her because it was a mistake sadly
holly threatens him that he will regret
what he did last weekend the next day
alison and holly decide to go to the
cafe where tyler works
there holly shows alison a photo of a
man whose face is invisible
tyler is terrified that she will tell
allison about their backstreet
relationship but luckily she still keeps
the secret holly begins to hang out and
grows closer to them by the day she also
often goes to allison's house to chat in
the meantime tyler wants to confess to
alison about his affair with holly via
text but then holly decides to stay in
allison's house causing him to delay
telling her the secret while alison is
sleeping holly secretly takes some of
alison's belongings and also a photo of
tyler with alison
as time passes tyler begins to suspect
that holly is dangerous
especially one day when he meets her
stepmother corrine who reveals that
holly is taking medication for a mental
disorder
she seems to have an obsession about
something that she loves
soon lydia becomes suspicious of holly
when she discovers holly's lack of any
social media presence
according to her everyone must have a
social media account nowadays but oddly
she doesn't have one holly inadvertently
overhears the conversation and feels
threatened while they are in the
cafeteria holly intentionally brings
their favorite smoothies to the table
with one specially poisoned for lydia
lydia instantaneously has a very severe
allergic reaction after drinking the
poison smoothie so she has to be rushed
to the hospital allison straightaway
escorts her to the hospital while tyler
guesses that his suspicions come true
at one time allison tells tyler that
holly is pregnant he initially doesn't
believe that their previous relationship
could get holly pregnant as a good
friend allison decides to accompany her
through her difficult times
holly later shows up at tyler's house
playing with tiffany she tells him that
she wants the two of them to get back
together but tyler quickly takes her out
by force and pushes her away from his
life forever
after tyler rebukes her she comes to
alison's house and tells her everything
that she and tyler slept together last
weekend as well as the photo of a man
that has been seen before styler at the
same night tyler visits lydia at the
hospital to tell her that he suspects
that holly put something in lydia's
smoothie earlier he also promises to
solve all the problems by telling
allison everything he did before
the next morning tyler and alison meet
at the beach where he confesses
everything to her alison has known the
truth from holly and decides to ignore
his explanation
she is very upset and states that she
never wants to talk to him again before
leaving him alone
at school holly then proceeds to get
tyler suspended from the school
indefinitely by telling the teacher that
he assaulted her while on suspension
tyler finds out from the teacher that
holly's real name is elizabeth
then he looks her up online and
unexpectedly discovers that she
violently assaulted another female
student and was committed to a mental
institution for a while as a result now
he knows why lydia couldn't find holly's
identity earlier on the internet because
she is a dangerous person
that night holly quietly breaks into
allison's house
she manages to kidnap alison and then
tries to lure tyler into her house by
sending him a picture of an unconscious
allison he plans to go there to save
alison while texting gil to help him
there by sending holly's home address
meanwhile ali awakens to find that she
has been tied up to a chair at holly's
house
holly starts telling allison that she's
not actually pregnant she purposely
tricked her to make her feel
disappointed with tyler
shortly after corinne comes home and
finds allison tied up she attempts to
rescue allison nevertheless holly sneaks
up behind her and suffocates her with a
plastic bag killing her when tyler
arrives at holly's house he grabs a
sharp iron just in case something bad
happens then he finds an unconscious
allison with blood on her forehead who
has been tied mid-air to the ceiling he
manages to free alison and they escape
outside before they can get away
suddenly holly points a gun at them
tyler apologizes to her for everything
he's done so far
fortunately gill arrives at the right
time from behind but this takes holly by
surprise causing her to shoot tyler
right in his shoulder all of a sudden
with that moment alison quickly takes
the sharp iron which tyler has brought
to stab holly tyler who is dying says in
his heart that love is blind and love
can destroy everything but he is lucky
that he and alison can survive the
tragedy they end happily celebrating
tiffany's birthday party at the end
holly who is still alive is wheeled into
the back of an ambulance and asks the
paramedic man to never leave her and
makes him promise
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching